aber ich bin rein gefallen wo wir kurz
in der englisch hausen auch noch igel
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
von wahr oder falsch endlich mal wieder
zu einer neuen
wir haben alle dinge verändert weil da
ist unsere alte firma da steht und wir
haben die reihenfolge geändert nein wir
wollen dass das ist eine obligatorische
staffel 2 wo ihr uns jetzt eine map
bauen könnt und das erste waren unsere
cook staffel die das scheiß und dass die
app das ein bisschen gefeiert
ein bisschen weiter fingern oder ein
bisschen krasser und ich wollte jetzt
aber zu sein alter mehr gefragt
die neue folge aber wir hatten ja sieben
aufgenommen wieder weiß dauert alles
diesem thema simon den wir sie so
bedeute dass du dieses mal ja als wir
auf der gamescom waren lüge wie waren
gar nicht da haben wir auch unter
anderem winsen von die wie move
getroffen und irgendwie ein bisschen ich
sage so freundschaftlich umarmt
aber irgendwie habe ich ihn dabei ein
bisschen an den arsch gefasst ich weiß
bis heute nicht warum das wasser wird
ihnen mit moment also manchmal macht man
das eine lüge
das ist ich weiß ich dass es so
grottenschlechte dachte bestimmt wir
sagen das war grottenschlecht aber
deswegen was falsch aber bestimmt was
für ein schritt weitergedacht und den
komplexen verfahren das nach weiter
gedacht
wir müssen alte nummer zwei das
vertrauen
es war meine erste story wir waren in
der dritten klasse auf klassenfahrt oder
was heißt klassenfahrt also blender
klassenfahrt wir waren ein tag weg wären
auf dem bauernhof gepennt insam
strohballen
und die lagen gewann hält wir haben uns
halt damals immer sowie bücher über
seine bücher plattform unterhalten da
kommt man bücher lesen und nachher
fragen zu dem buch beantworten haben
dafür die punkte schreibt meine
kommentare für das noch kennt jedenfalls
dass eine gruppe gemacht so illegal dann
gesagt dass wir wären wir da sind dass
wir dann so spiele spielen wir haben
sowohl wahrheit pflicht und so und wer
das alles spielt umsatz 5 jugend vier
mädels oder so in seinem krad in der
dritten klasse und auf einmal keiner der
jungen dem zeit wo man diese richtigen
dritte klasse erhält das erste mal
ausprobiert er hat halt einfach gedacht
damit einen mückenstich gab ja bei uns
werden heute gebannt
wurst los jungs werberat gemacht weil
simon ungestört hier reinkam der blöde
ps
aber wenn man mit ganz viel herzen und
bibel begrüßt selbstverständlich gehören
ich habe zwei bücher wusste ich habe
keines mutter gepflegt
hubert
über diese kurze und ich war nicht dabei
war nicht auf der gamescom der war du
schwul bist bist du deine story was er
redet mit zwei minuten später konnte der
herd er hat bisher so viel geschafft hat
er gesagt hat dass sie auf der gamescom
nach hause gefahren
walter an diesem tag fertig waren die
trotz dieser taxi hat eine komische
sprache redet die keiner von uns
verstanden als taxi taxi hatten das
halbtax hier hat eine komische sprachen
geredet ja dann sind wir die autobahn
gefahren
die autobahn gibt es nicht das war schön
du bist das war nichts was den jet über
die 84
jetzt halt dein maul komme auf den punkt
jetzt okay so
das verstehst du gut waren wir endlich
da mussten irgendwie um die 7 50 euro
bezahlen was recht teuer war total und
ich sag mal so weit und ich war gut
dabei dann haben wir uns haben sich da
unsere wege getrennt wir sind jeweils
nach hause gegangen und vor meinem haus
ist so gebüsch zu voll ich wollte er ein
kotzen
aber ich bin hereingefallen ich denke wo
wir kurz mir leid in englisch hausen
auch noch igel ja ich bin also in diesem
fall mit dem händler voraus mit der
rechten hand offen liegen deine hand
autobahn gefahren lauern gefahren war
es war nicht falsch
ein buch wie hey ich habs doch richtig
ich schwöre beim ich die flüge drin
du hast du hast falsch gesagt nicht lüge
lass dir plötzlich eine art am kopf
wieder munter auf ist also ich habe
heute mein promoter bleibt doch stehen
alter denkt man in der scheiße da kommt
man nicht dazu sagen nicht nein ich weiß
dass sie das kind das kennt mich jeder
auch ihre dieses video kommt auch die
frauen werden nicht gebracht ist stimme
aber generell am mittag den etwa abends
und ich wollte ein schlaflabor dann wenn
sich ein ja und dann habe ich aufgehört
zu youtube
ich weiß nicht ich wünsche mir dass es
war es war heiss war es ist einfach wahr
aber sofort gekommen
lebensgefährlicher 20 liter sperma
abschießen
ja bei mir vor zwei wochen oder so ich
war mein fahrrad zur schule und ich hab
so ein damenrad wenn ich nicht vergesse
papier unteren linken hier sondern will
hier rein
die meinrad aussieht aussage jedenfalls
ja ich musste es halt nehmen wenn man
alte zwei wochen vorher von einer party
geklaut wurde
dann hatte ich halt das von meiner
mutter und das wald des todes feuer und
ich war damit einfacher dem ersten tag
wo ich haben
ich fahre über eine kreuzung und es
bricht mir durch jetzt bricht mir auf
der kreuzung durch
es bricht einfach in der mitte es ist
nicht an
es ist nicht an der stelle
durchgebrochen wo diese oder so
verbunden ist oder so festgelegt
geschweißt ist das ist einfach davor
durchgebrochen
mitten auf der kreuzung mit zwei teilen
und ich habe mir nicht sorgen um meine
gesundheit gemacht hat mich viel mehr
gedacht scheiße wie viele leute um mich
herum lachen mich gerade aus steht
eigentlich dante einfach und das hatte
ich noch nie wenn man platten hat dann
kann man nicht mehr weiterfahren wenn
man die gangschaltung in die kaputt ist
oder so aber ich stand ja echt einfach
mit zwei teile des tages auf meinem
sattel und ich hatte in der vorderhand
ein lenker und konnte den zug durch die
luft drehen und alles mögliche und ich
stand da wird seither mit einer krücke
dich gesagt sorry sorry an alle musste
ich wegen der anhaltenden runter und ich
war so danach am lachen er es war
unglaublich bin zwar 15 minuten später
zur schule gekommen
aber ich mache ich halt einfach zwei
teile der hand auf einmal mitmachen
einfach in mir durchgebrochen ist das
eine
lüge dem bild sind ja ich kann euch wild
sein von dem fahrrad das kann ich auch
einfach einblenden stimmt und wenn ihr
euch dann ein
er warte mal wie viele bücher hast du
malte und manuell ich habe auch viel
okay okay die freundliche letzte schafft
das erste alter
wer das zuletzt 1 punkte machen aber
jetzt macht ihr einen sushi und einer
sagt war einerseits falsch wenn ich sie
schon kommen müssen wir dürfen uns frei
entscheiden
ja ja wir können eins-gegen-eins battle
da machen seid ihr bereit was okay
endlich kann ich diesen satz wieder
ernst hat seine kollegen feiern dann die
waren so ein klub da haben schon gut
kurze gekippt und alles denken es okay
jetzt gehen wir ein bisschen tanzen sind
wir da fehlen dann sieht der kollege von
mir richtig richtig geile sau
betrieb eines einfachen schwein
einverstanden ich stand da und dann
weiblich okay meinte stand das werde sei
wie 2.0 gewesen alter oder halt für von
crafter christi mac oder halt london
und was ist ein silberner jetzt bist du
schon ganz gut da hatte ich auch schon
ein kollege geht's dahin
damals ist mir ja ich kenne hier hat der
schöne der pizza tanzt sie an immer
weiter und weiter
der gefällt das auch noch auf einmal
kommt ihr macker siebte kolleg richtige
durch auf die schläfen gehirnerschüttung
wird noch auf der tanzfläche gekotzt und
musste ins krankenhaus wegen malte nur
bei malte da stand heute mal was zum
kotzen zu tun
ich weiß nicht ist es liebe da war ich
würde sagen sieht darin die zweite
überhaupt da gab es eine lüge
ich glaube dass händels ich bin hier der
charity übertriebene analyse gemacht
ich bin ich noch nicht
wir könnten davon nicht abhalten die
gäste den ball - ich sag es ist eine
lüge
da gib mir das ergebnis stimmt alter
junge das kann doch nicht sein alter wie
kommst du dich denn bitte retten
das kann auch nicht sein war steht jetzt
viel 44 oder milch ja aber wie krake wie
kann die warum ich stehe einfach in der
letzten runde 44 2 und er schafft es
einfach dass wir beide falsch liegen
und yeah und weite wiesen auch noch so
dumme machen beide das gleiche alter es
ist unglaublich
bald ist einfach nur traurig steht er
wie schafften allerdings steht einfach
ich bin da du musst dein kopf zur seite
die hockey welt ehrlich gesagt wir ein
unentschieden einfach meine gemerkt was
einfallen lassen dass jeder von uns ein
eisenbahn hat einen obligatorischen
eisenbahn
ihr könnt uns maps bauen mit am besten
so redstone kacke und so irgendwie wenn
das hotel in das wenn man das falsch ist
wenn man dann dass man dann einfach im
gegenstand ihn reinwerfen muss ja
irgendwie sowas
und dann wird das eben geblinkt
vielleicht könnte das er machen dass wir
auf jeden fall mal geile würde immer von
uns in einen gesagt bekommen der
beschreibung wir würden euch hat
allgemein täter lieben können uns auch
per mail schreiben damit diesmal mussten
uns genommen weil er das der opfer
wollte und dann würde ich sagen die
nächste folge ist wann bereichen folge
sind kollegen feiern auf burgen zooms tv
alter mann
die nächsten folgen noch im spital am
nächsten montag oder schon
ja ich weiß nicht was waren
was montag montag immer montags zog er
immer montags ab
also wenn du dich gerade seht ist der 21
am 28 folge bei broken fans könnte
hätten wir die ganzen fertig dass ihr es
euch gefällt könnt ihr eure daumen
abreißen und auf video pin
das wird uns auf jeden fall freuen macht
das besser nicht
der beginn